So, these food delivery apps are still growing.
They're just growing more slowly.
So, what are companies like DoorDash and Uber Eats doing...
...to keep customers spending money?
Right, so, they have rolled out a host of measures this year.
One is just they sweetening the deal...
...to try to convince customers to become subscribers.
Now, subscribers pay a monthly fee, but they enjoy discounts on food.
They enjoy no delivery fees.
And from the company's perspective,...
...subscribers actually spend a lot more than non-subscribers,...
...and they have higher-order values.
So, it's in their best interest to get as many customers to become subscribers.
And then, what the apps are also doing is they're tweaking their apps...
...to trigger more spending...
...and moving beyond food to give people more reasons to return.
So, you know, you can now order everything from toothpaste to toilet paper...
...to your groceries to flowers,...
...even a Thanksgiving turkey on, you know, DoorDash and Uber Eats.
And as far as restaurants are concerned,...
...they're negotiating deals to keep them from increasing delivery prices.
So, DoorDash negotiated a deal with McDonald's,...
...where they can't raise delivery prices more than 30% of what the in-store price is.
And at the same time, they are also diversifying beyond delivery...
...and offering new services to restaurants.